[Music]
oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
the revolution's Upon Us my friends hey
can I get a whale for everybody who's
afraid of nuclear war
a little bit right not me yeah I'm built
differently I'm waiting I've been
playing Fallout New Vegas I played all
the fallouts dude drive on chaos you
don't understand I have in an entire
room in my in my seven grillion dollar
compound dedicated to a bottle cap
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists let's go
yeah I I I'm ready yeah I mean
theoretically we are safe down here in
our 20 billion dollar bunker but yeah I
get a little nervous when I see like
Elon Musk is talking to Putin and the
thing is like in Silicon Valley and all
these billionaires they all have their
own apocalypse bunker so maybe they're
like they're awesome with the idea
they're all in New Zealand I don't think
anyone like I don't think anyone
actually is okay with it like just
because you can survive potentially
survive nuclear fallout doesn't
necessarily mean it's gonna be a fun
time you know what I mean like I don't
think
there's no cheery Utopias about nuclear
uh fallout it's always a dystopia you
know you can I believe an individual
citizen in this country has a right to
own a nuclear warhead except for Tim Tim
does legitimately want it he wants it
bad he wants everybody to have nukes the
n-word the thing is uh you know Elon
could become king though he could
recreate the world and his as he sees it
I know but if you're if you're king of
uh a completely destroyed landscape with
no human beings out there I mean what's
the point like I don't want to just be
king for the virtue of being King
I know I'm saying like men does not want
to be king
for simply the virtue of being King you
want to you want to rule over something
that's something that you want to
prescribe
yeah I mean
I'm sure there's a short Shakespearean
play about someone who made his King on
Ash and you know that's it right yeah
that's it but that sucks then you're
just like you know you're the king of
Ash more like the king of ass got him
more like the king of being ashy
[ __ ] yeah but no welcome back uh Hassan
uh you had a you were at the twitchcon
AV was there did you guys ever did you
guys run into each other no no you were
probably in there you're probably in the
Big Time area you have like an army of
people following him everywhere yeah it
was it was a little it was a little
hectic I won't lie I mean I love I love
meeting fans it's my favorite thing I
love doing that sort of stuff but it
gets a little it gets hectic every time
I do this sort of thing it gets more and
more hectic I feel like
and twitchcon this year was just like oh
my God I there was every time I stood in
one place I had security
every time I sit in one place for longer
than like
30 seconds there would be a crowd of
like 60 to 100 people formed around me
right yeah I mean it's crazy yeah but
there's not like a special area for you
guys you big crew we do we we have like
I mean we do of course there's like
there's lounges and stuff like that but
I don't I mean I I go back there every
now and then you know just get some get
some water and stuff but other than that
I'm Swan diving into the crowd all the
time that's a lot that seems intense
well I just the way I see it is that uh
you know these people have one shot at
getting to meet you and if uh they're
watching me for eight hours a day
you know what I mean I I might have
helped them get through some tough times
and that's usually what I hear from a
lot of people
um and this is the one moment that they
have to get to meet me take photo with
me I'm gonna I'm gonna make sure I mean
it's it's important for them okay we
love that uh a king a command of the
people did anyone brandish did anyone
try to stab you or anything like that no
not that I we love that that's good
no one tried to wear your skin no I mean
we there were some touch and go moments
but it's whatever it wasn't that big of
a deal
no attempts on your life no attempts on
my life there is something here that was
kind of a problem for me I mean what are
you doing what the [ __ ] is this bro are
you trying because I kissed young gravy
last night
also Carl Jacob's like stay in your age
range bro how old is Carl Jacobs this is
a problematic age gap for sure yeah how
old is he he's like 18 bro oh no he's
like he's like 23 24 I think but you
know still that automatic age guy that's
six years man seven years uh it's not
that bad
he does look 18 though yeah he looked
he's a young he's a young boy
Carl's the man all right so you're out
there kissing guys you're fighting in
the Death Pit which by the way I wanted
to ask you about the death pick because
we were talking about it yesterday how
so many people got injured somebody
broke their [ __ ] back in this goddamn
thing another person dislocated Adriana
hey Adriana uh jumped into the pit uh
dove into the pit after her victory yeah
um and and and you know broke her
tailbone I believe her she had such
severe spinal injuries that she had to
get spinal surgery immediately
um multiple rods were placed in her
multiple metal rods replaced in her
spine she has no bladder control at the
moment I mean you know I hope she's
doing all right uh hopefully her
recovery is Swift uh but who knows who
knows what will happen those things are
no joke right so how [ __ ] up was this
ball pit I mean you know what's crazy
yeah this is after that we didn't even
know but they kept it going yeah awesome
yeah did they keep it open the whole
time I think so I think the exception of
the last day they closed the last day
only they closed the last day but this
is like we closed it out on on Saturday
we closed it out but who knows sorry
yeah uh xqc and I uh duked it out you
know what I mean we gotta take a look
yeah finally we got our licks in no more
balls on his face
I mean this is you got like a hundred
pounds on him probably yeah
what is wrong with you but take the L
[ __ ] too bad he's not the one that
broke his back oh chill okay I don't
want I don't want why did good things
happen why do bad things happen to good
people I'm just saying so
um
yeah XTC and I duked it out twice he
wanted to smoke twice
and I and I ripped them yeah of course I
ripped them big time he could take you
out man yeah we um we actually uh you
know by way of Ludwig have already
communicated uh I had like even before
twitchcon
about uh his uh his heavy implication in
me uh making it seem like I knew and and
was like undermining sexual assault
allegations and stuff like that we had
hash it out on my podcast verified that
publicly yeah okay on my podcast he did
at my other party he said he said those
things just because he was angry right
yeah so that's really not that's
probably like kind of a bad thing no he
knows actually sound very good when you
say it like that no he he yeah I mean he
admitted it he was like listen I I
[ __ ] up I'm sorry
all this stuff all this [ __ ] like him
saying all this stuff he he just
straight up admitted he was like I don't
believe in any of that I just said it
because I knew I know other people
believe in it and they're gonna get mad
and repeat it yeah [ __ ] kind of [ __ ]
up yeah I mean just Tim Paul after
apologizing for but that's pretty low
life [ __ ] I mean look we'll see only
time will tell you know what I mean but
the good news is nobody will ever
turn on our juicer as you see it will
never happen yeah but the good news is
we got the best sound bites uh that we
could ever that's true exactly get your
balls off my face man
I love that I love that one that one's
great
um speaking of the podcast uh you I I
have people who you are lovers with on
the podcast like Jeff woodek yeah and
then I have people apparently without
even realizing that you have beef with
on the podcast
the sway bars okay they called it I saw
I'm looking at it right now okay yeah
let me pull this up yeah the sway boys
went on your uh fear and pod yeah and um
Carl Jacob again bro what's going on I
love I love why are you making me he's
out he's out in L.A Alice bro you
kissing him he's on your podcast Carl's
the number one homie hopper yeah that's
what they call him in the Minecraft
Community but yeah no I love Carl he's
great
yes so here's Bryce Hall and uh what's
his name
uh Jared Joshua Richards Josh yeah he's
a Josh he's Josh Richards and and Bryce
Hall Bryce is actually pretty nice so
I'm I'm I don't know what you're about
to say to him I will say about him
rather like I was actually shocked
because I I first met him when I went on
a tiny meat gang with Cody and Noel and
they had like an intro skit like a
sketch that they had filmed with them
that they were going to film with them
rather and they kind of just like
dropped them on me on my [ __ ]
interview I was like damn bro I'm not
good enough on my own you had to bring
it I didn't do that like the top Viner
what is this [ __ ] I mean Avon you're
[ __ ] I'm so old tick tocker
and and they were like no no no whatever
but it was funny it was funny I did odd
that they paired the two of you guys but
it worked well though it was a funny
Dynamic yeah so I saw this clip and my
reaction is actually pretty funny let me
just show you guys what they said about
the H3 yeah it's called leftovers he
hates me yeah oh Ethan Klein right yeah
he hates me too
bring it up on the next box yeah yo I
had Bryce Hall and Josh and just I hate
him because they are on my lawn all the
time damn it those boys don't know how
to respect the good alone
is it like the the party I didn't know
these were the party guys
I don't know if they're the covered
party guys oh that's yeah yeah yeah I
mean Bryce was I don't know about this
dude the other one was he's Dave
portnoy's uh co-host yeah so he's caught
in the crossfire every now and then yeah
it'd be funny if he didn't and there
were just doing this so that they would
get in that podcast yeah what the [ __ ] I
have no idea he is [ __ ] on my life
multiple times really wait really this
shit's on me did we cut it should we cut
them no no no I'll be honest I don't I
don't have beef with them and I don't
really I mean I've talked about them a
few times but I don't really know what
they're talking about
wait really yeah well I think just
because you like casually may talk [ __ ]
here and there they think you hate them
but that's just that's how you talk
that's just well well okay
wash it first of all this man is in the
Crosshair of some really Heavy Hitters
oh that he's like that wait that's
Harvey Weinstein yes indeed it's so hard
to tell but that's actually Ryan
Cavanaugh wait what stop so hard to tell
the difference stop
he looks more puffy no get away get away
Bryce you look so puffy and red and it's
too much wine sorry his teeth drinking
weird the man what happened do you get
red when you drink a lot of alcohol if
you're an alcoholic yeah you're just
getting pigment yes that might be what's
going on with it I don't know I mean you
don't have a comment on that I mean I I
I I don't want to get sued man well next
to Bryce Bryce skin looks good but
yeah Bryce is looking beefy he's looking
so thick he's looking nice with it yeah
get away from him Harvey don't do it
it's a Beefcake I've said nice things
about Bryce I think I you know we the
only thing I can think of other than the
covet parties where you ever went in on
Bryce was there was some video where he
was beefing with somebody and he showed
up at their house and tried to fight him
wait you know what I'm talking about but
this was years ago yeah yeah well you
kind of dedicated a front of me segment
to it it was right I remember we talked
about on Frenemies and he showed up at
somebody's house and was like getting in
their face and it was pretty dude it was
a few years ago it was a while ago yeah
but that's the only thing that comes to
mind where you like to marry the hatchet
it's up to you I think I think I'm
offered a bear I'd love to bury the
hatchet with uh Bryce young Bryce Hall
I'll be the mediator
um in fact didn't we invite him on at
some point or you tweeted him last
summer yeah and he said yes I think he
even was down yeah what are you big time
you're like no no no I think he Big Time
To Me Wait really no shots he's with cab
cap so so he's yeah that's big star cap
starting a a video production company
which of course he has a great history
of that yeah it always goes great
relativity media of course he he uh
bankrupted that because I don't know
he's also anti-vaxx apparently but okay
whatever oh yeah he wasn't vaccinated he
wanted to come in during the like I was
like just we were asking all of our
guests to show proof of vaccination and
he's like no I'm not doing it yeah
that's crazy well yeah I'll ask him I
didn't blast him for that though thing I
was just like you know yeah I don't
think he's like well then we're not
doing it
I mean I don't get I don't blame him
dude broadcast mediation session where
we vaccinate them that'd be awesome
let's give him the jab so funny some
[ __ ] Clockwork speaking of
vaccinations this is a tangent it's
unrelated but did you see M.I.A
yummy stupid I like their stupid dog
[ __ ] it up yeah I just I can't
believe it dude apparently apparently
she became like a born-again Christian
for the record for those of you who
don't know Alex Jones got hit with a fat
lawsuit we're probably gonna talk about
it a little bit but yes uh and then
M.I.A like is a take on that was like oh
if Alex Jones is getting hit with
defamation what about if Alex Jones has
to pay a billion dollars to like victims
of Sandy Hook then what about all the
celebrities that lied to care people
about the vacuum yes I don't know I
think she just has that all I wanna bing
bing bing boom is take your money yeah
and we all had so much fun with that
song we all cherished that song it's not
just that like M.I.A you know she's uh
she's a brown artist in the UK you know
what I mean like in it I think I think
she was always
she always had like decent political
takes too I think she was like overly
political and then apparently during
covet she had a born-again Christian
phase dude nothing nothing is worse than
your brain on your brain than being a
born-again Christian I mean that is you
better you're better they're going
boring again Mike Pence I mean that's
like 90 American Mike Liddell it's dude
your brain on Born Again Jesus is like
yeah shouts out the crack
I don't know man it seems like he was
better on crack yeah yeah so she goes if
Alex Jones is paying for lying shouldn't
every celebrity pushing vaccines paid to
115 000 likes that's crazy well there's
a lot 150 000 [ __ ] were like
the hell yeah that's great that's a
great take or no sorry they were like
hell that's a great [ __ ] type MRI I'm
a imma be
I'll be back give me that money ring
ring ring no give me your money you got
to do it you gotta do it in the asset
you gotta be like yeah you're all
developing shows praise for lawyers
shouldn't every celebrity push in
vaccines by two brexit was a [ __ ]
great idea mate I've never heard you do
a British accent what was it that it's a
work in progress yeah but I think it's
Americans that are liking this tweet
yeah probably but I mean British people
probably do I don't know British people
are pretty dumb I mean demonetized you
hear that and oh I was trying to pull up
just the uh the sound effect part so I
could uh accompany you and you're
playing with oh yeah why are you trying
to bro why are you playing with my back
this stream is literally called uh uh
Mia paper planes edit just the sound
effects but clearly that was uh bro why
are you paying with my bag I'm gonna
deduct that from your paycheck all right
give me your money talk it
um yeah she's an idiot there's a lot of
dumb people in the world I've been
watching a reality show based in the UK
dating show and he's what is it love
Island
it's uh oh a twin Dating Game yo it's
called related and dated on Netflix
anyway they're mostly English and they
are just bottom they're so dumb wait
related and dated mostly English people
oh shocker
why do did the English know for
inbreeding I mean the Royals the Royals
but that's a specialty that's like and
that's what happens when you're [ __ ]
stuck on an island for a thousand years
I mean pretty small island too so yeah a
lot a lot of inbreed not a lot of folks
out here in it yeah that's like Southern
oh wait speaking of incest
just because I'm gonna skip around a
little bit I have a related video
yeah oh let's go this [ __ ] right
in on that little island baby he's just
he want to be Cardy so bad he just wants
to be British so bad dude you can't so
this is this is a great would you
consider this a great uh conservative
thinker they consider him right I think
he's the best he's brilliant one of the
top dogs
University named after him yeah not fake
real real University it's just a YouTube
channel not one of those fakes like
Phoenix University or something like
this is a real one
accredited yeah so he's going the route
of saying that we everybody gets their
morality from uh the Bible and uh well
he's got no he had a Checkmate atheist
argument and I was checkmated okay I had
not I had not considered incest is
wincest before Dennis Prager dropped
these hot truth bombs on me basically
what I heard was he wants to [ __ ] his
sister yeah no hot truth bombs and hot
loads inside of his sister yeah
I say Prager because I don't give a [ __ ]
but I think it's breaker okay okay all
right here he is
let's see here human slug God you just
you just hate him because he's always
the line just admit it you hate him
because he's hot
he's so funny he is
I see what you're doing
he is the most repulsive man he's so
sexy you just you're just you're just
hating on him for for being sexy as [ __ ]
three-time Divorce Court Champion Dennis
Prager just some just imagine that
someone's had sex with that man oh many
many women all over them many women
haven't potentially allegedly against
their will considering his own writings
on the subject matter right uh famously
wrote when a woman isn't in the mood
part one and was like damn that was so
far I gotta drop the second one and then
wrote when a woman isn't in the mood
part two where he justifies uh spousal
rape marital rape well who would sleep
with him willingly
at the end of the day sister potentially
I mean let's let's take a look what does
he say all right let's watch the whole
thing okay I'm not pausing it dude okay
bro try it don't say [ __ ] to me okay
dude okay how about wait at least 30
seconds I'm just gonna be hard I'm gonna
hold on
let's see here
public nudity calls are interesting hey
Pops
anyway none of you have a secular
argument again sitting I don't blame you
for that because
it uh there isn't any
there's no secular argument against
adult incest what about childhood
brother and sister want to make love
what's your argument
that they're going to produce mentally
[ __ ] Offspring drops it
takes many generations of inbreeding to
do that can we yeah did I make it to 30
yeah I did see 36 seconds yeah can we
get a sound bite of him staying mentally
uh forwarded uh re retired or whatever
yeah you started
he just there is no secular argument
against
adult consensual incest bro is this what
you talk about on your radio show
yeah what do you mean when you have a
radio show I thought this is exactly
what you talk about adult incest guy I
love you I love it so much look
everybody everybody has the age-old like
Checkmate atheist argument like if you
ever had a r slash Reddit atheist phase
or anything you've encountered this
argument a million times right like the
the notion that like morality comes from
the Bible yeah it's a bit of a
self-report in my opinion anytime
someone's like well you know if it
wasn't for the Bible people will be out
there murdering each other I'll be like
uh well one they still do it and two the
[ __ ] it's not the Bible That's stopping
people from doing that you want to just
do that that's crazy right
um
but this one is probably the worst like
it's the worst
mathematical way to go about describing
incest as like a bad thing
because he's basically saying it's
actually good if it wasn't for the Bible
he says we'd all be doing it he
basically is he says first of all he
says adult consensual love here just
keep going he has a point sex cannot
enter family life
it's a big taboo
I do it with everyone see people think
that we could live without the greatest
source of wisdom and Morality In The
History of the World the Bible that's
what they think there's a point where he
says he's such an idiot secular
conservatives think that people all
around the world living without the
Bible completely fine man no there's a
point where he actually in the beginning
I think I missed it where he literally
says like you know a wonderful loving
relationship between brother and sister
and I was like why would you use those
terms like
and I mean look my man knows his
audience he's like he saw his numbers
dipping in Alabama and he was like we
gotta we gotta dip back into that pool I
know we're gonna go out there Brothers
in Alabama yeah that's a different kind
of family we know you out there brothers
and sisters you want to [ __ ] your dear
brother
now let me tell you now resist that urge
Lord
it just makes it more sexy if you can
resist yeah yeah he's like just let the
tension build up
but like technically you're not even
doing it for inbreeding reasons like for
genetic reasons apparently according to
Dennis Prager you're doing it because
the Bible told you not to he says yet
another thing the Bible is trying to
stop you from having fun with if you ask
me okay no fun having ass Bible I'll
tell you who does allow incest Satan
which is another reason I'm going to
hell to [ __ ] have a good old time
yeah all ever hell's a party well Dennis
preacher's definitely going to hell so I
don't know
I don't realize that living on the fumes
of the judeo-christian value system
but if you ultimately extract those
flowers from the soil that nurtured them
those flowers will wither and die
I don't want to see that happen so I am
working so hard on this commentary and
you're working too hard and he's saving
Our Lives he's saving America he's
saving the world with his commentary he
really sounds close to death here's now
just to deconstruct his point which is
so stupid it's like
he says we'd all be [ __ ] our our
siblings
if it didn't say in the Bible not to do
that first of all before the Bible
I'm pretty sure there's not a lot of
record of instance was like a common
practice I don't think before I mean
humans have been civilization's been
around for a hundred thousand years plus
I don't think everyone's [ __ ] their
sibling and the reason for that is that
well you know who did the First Act of
incest Adam and Eve I mean technically
Eve is literally a part of Adam's Rib
you know what I mean this isn't a bridge
version you're right and they piped it
up so there's a lot of conflicting
stories within the Bible here you know
what's going on you technically Eve is
from Adam's Rib therefore you could say
Eve is Adam's child therefore the
original Act of incest is how human
Humanity started yeah I mean that's why
I believe in Scientology instead yeah
I mean it's true we all started from
Adam and Eve so I mean not the gene
pools are struggling there in the
beginning I believe in Scientology but
the black Israelite version the Eric
Andre L Ron Hoya bembe
Eric Andre yeah Eric Andre uh well I
mean this is a bit that he did but oh
okay thank God I I love I love thinking
that there would be a black Israelite
version of Scientology
and their L Ron Hubbard was a black man
El Ron Hoya bembe oh that is good that's
good
yeah I mean obviously I think there's a
biological
there's been actually studies about this
Prager if you looked into it you [ __ ]
pasty ass doughy little [ __ ] boy
um
there are there's something about when
you grow up with
a sibling in close proximity you have
this natural uh lessening of sexual
attraction to them it's some kind of
obviously genetically
uh Behavior that's encoded in our in our
DNA sexual for obvious reasons which is
that yeah reading with your immediate
family members is not does not producing
that's how you get the royal family dog
you want that [ __ ] I mean they have
traceable because of uh uh centuries of
oh here it is systemic inbreeding the
the royal bloodlines
yeah they did it they did all that or
they were so in they were so inbred they
were so intertwined with one another
their familiar relations were so close
that like I think in the in the Spanish
royalty where like the Habsburg jaw
comes from which is a traceable genetic
disability
uh that is directly a cause of of uh
inbreeding for centuries but it was so
it was it was uh so rampant oh God no
this is what happens guys it's sausage I
think the real Prager wants
yeah um but it was so it was so
traceable like that
for example distant cousins
that got married like the parents of
this uh sausage fingered fellow here
right uh it was actually much closer
genetically than than actual distant
cousins like normal in a normal
circumstance
yeah so dude didn't look very far uh the
West the Western Mark effect is a
psychological
hypothesis known as reverse sexual
imprinting
um people tend not to be attracted to
peers with whom they have lived like
siblings before the age of six uh excuse
me this actually uh this actually is
false have you seen step sibling porn
I know but but the imprint should work
because if they're you know well no four
six maybe you know what I mean just
saying Milk porn what have you seen uh
exploding Milk Bar oh yes breasts
uh actually the Westminster effect has
achieved some empirical support
yada yada yada maybe we'll send this to
Prager you can read up on it he says
there's no evidence but Prager go [ __ ]
your own sister who gives a [ __ ] I love
how he goes this he turns into a uh
it turns into like a uh
a sociologist here in a sec he goes for
that because
it uh there isn't any
there's no secular argument against
adult incest
brother and sister want to make love
what's your argument
that they're going to produce give me
one good reason that's what I'm saying
he's like he's like I'm asking like he
yeah
an answer brother and sister love dog
you didn't have to you didn't have to
ride so hard for incest you didn't have
to feel it
made close incestors talking about
cousins listen the incest Community
thanks him for for his support baby's
sad but no this is my favorite part he
goes
mentally [ __ ] Offspring oh Jesus
what's your argument yeah here that
they're going to produce mentally
[ __ ] offspring
it's nonsense it is many generations
have been breathing I think it increases
the likelihood that you will uh what is
it like no no no there's like a there's
a Code perverts love talking about this
[ __ ] it's like their favorite thing uh
but um I think like incestuous
relationships especially between close
siblings brother has a chance to to
increase uh genetic disabilities
but uh not entirely certain if it's like
off of the uh yeah there's a coefficient
of it so Prager this is good for you you
might want to Crunch the numbers here
coefficients of inbreeding is an
individual is the probability that two
uh well lots of scientific two allows
any Locus in an individual are identical
from December common ancestors or two
parents the coefficiency of inbreeding
is the probably the two allows that are
given Locus an identical descent let's
give me the numbers man how what if I
have a baby with my sister how many
fingers is gonna have
tell me
yeah
anyway the guy's a freak this is what
this is what the right wing conservatism
looks like and that's Dennis Prager and
that's your brain on Jesus
I rest my case
thank you
M.I.A
go [ __ ] your brother or something
thank you I rest my case
yeah I don't have a problem with Bryce
Hall and it would go back to this but I
wanted to tell you about cavcv so he
made this video production company
he's only making videos with Tick Tock
Stars
Bryce Hall
the demelios
there was someone else who was it
I'll check
it's the whole demilio family that's
right this is his big old this is his
plan to get paid to get paid and so
Bryce is Golden Boy so I think there's
some friction there but I love to make
up with Bryce I mean obviously
um I love to try to poison his brain
against kevkev as well I don't don't
Reveal Your
why do you always do this I'm just being
honest you just you you reveal what you
would do eventually uh even if you're
gonna do it you don't have to fight bro
I say I speak facts only oh God I will
Bryce I will tell you I will poison your
mind against your benefits well now he's
never gonna come cab is not gonna want
him
Coalition Bryce win that [ __ ] goes belly
up which it will the man's never run a
successful business in his life come and
we can talk shop about kav Kev the man
is a [ __ ] loser degenerate freak and
he's got the growing lead his he's
starting to look more and more like a
glass of wine he's been drinking so much
of it thank you
too much wine sorry and this kid I don't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
yeah Josh Richards yeah he's on Barstool
and uh
I don't think I've said that I don't
think he really said anything negative
about him you're always just making fun
of Dave port pork we may have lately
[ __ ] on him a little bit I don't think
so I think my comments were pretty much
like why is Dave making a podcast with
an 18 year old or something like that
but I guess maybe it's a little
dismissive of him but I don't think I've
[ __ ] all over his life or whatever you
know come on Bryce let's talk shots yeah
invite him on Hassan we can do a Bryce
Hall special here on let's do it I'm
down
sloppy leftovers we'll call it because
of
kav Kev likes that sloppy seconds all
right
moving on
um here's a great story thank you
the Bull's angry
this story is awesome uh
yeah
we watched I think we watched this video
a minute ago
this guy there was a hate crime abide in
hate crime absolutely
terrible stuff here
someone burned down this dude's camper
and car and they spraying painted
vicious hateful slogans like Biden 2020
which as you really [ __ ] up which as
you know all violent vigilante yeah
trigger warning uh you're gonna see some
really horrifying hate speech here yeah
plastered all over she's now joining
well investigation everyone thought it
was fake obviously because like who the
[ __ ] I didn't I knew it was real and in
my heart it still is
so I hope there certainly isn't any new
information that came out about this
particular subject yes now joining the
investigation
now we're joining the investigation into
a suspicious fire at the home of a trump
supporter a trump flag a garage and
several cars all going up in Flames oh
Fox 9's Courtney horrible towards the
homeowners it's horrible I feel like if
we didn't wake up I feel like it could
have gotten to our house as you can see
right there
the siding and everything it just
started melting the windows on this side
already shattered yeah security footage
shows the moment Dennis and Deanna mola
run outside to find their garage and
several cars on fire I Woke Up This is
tragic
eight as we know from our ring camera
very loud explosions
[Music]
in the house before Flames left their
Brooklyn Center driveway and Ashes
police captured this photo spray painted
on their garage this is my favorite [ __ ]
bro you were fighting 2020 BLM and then
the anarch is a there those are in
contention I don't think yeah none of
those none of those dudes [ __ ] with each
other okay yeah like you put like every
leftist slogan that you think is left is
together okay that's what happened and
there ain't no Biden Stan out there
who's burning anyone's house down okay
yeah but 2020 [ __ ] die no they ride
they ride so hard
Biden 2020 BLM and an a with a circle
around it a commonly known symbol for
Anarchy we live in you know the greatest
country in the world and the greatest
thing about America is we have the right
to to say what we want to say and you
know be attacked for it and I think it's
totally been violated well anyway these
[ __ ] idiots the story keep it going
oh let them glow police believe the
couples targeted as they had a large
Trump flag displayed on the camper and
another flag on the back of one of their
man that's really [ __ ] up that they
did that because yeah unforgivable man I
wouldn't have gotten it you know I don't
want to deal with this at all [ __ ] why
are you wearing a mask yeah he's not a
real Trumper dude political sign up and
with two small children at home they say
this is like likely the last we feel
almost so silly that you know we could
have put our children's lives at risk
even even though it's not something that
should have been
it shouldn't have risked their lives in
the first place yeah horrible stuff well
it just came out don't don't tell me I
mean this is just this is an everyday
experience the Trump supporters I mean
they're always under attack Ethan Biden
20. this is fake the most fearsome words
I mean what people Department of Justice
announces a Brooklyn Center man has
pleaded guilty to wire fraud after
staging an arson what Dennis I know it
that's small it's a different person
right
no Dennis Wallace said the Vandal
sprayed Biden 2020 BLM and an antifa
symbol in his garage door then burned
his own camper or that then burned his
camera because he threw a drew a flew a
trump flag in reality mola started his
own property on
set his own property on fire and spray
painted the graffiti on his own garage
mola also created and allowed others to
create two GoFundMe accounts for himola
had uh three hundred thousand dollars in
fraudulent insurance claims come on man
and more than 17 000 from Individual
donors I gave him so much money Ethan
I gave him so much if I say be careful
go find me a song I took my I took all
the the child uh alimony the payments
that I had child support payments that I
had and gave it directly to this man
look at me egg on my face okay more
careful on the on that door
I mean it's so perfect they did this
they did this little wall remember that
guy who's like a quad quadriplegic uh
guy who who did the fake like we're
gonna build Trump's wall we're gonna
take matters into our own hands yep yep
and then they did wire fraud too it's
awesome milk these [ __ ] man
they're they got too much disposable
income okay every HVAC uh business owner
small business owner every [ __ ] you
know uh jet ski dealership owner that
was passed down to them by their dad all
these fail stones are like we got too
much money and nowhere to put it
it's so good
um well who would have thought and
actually it made me really sad when they
said they had kids I was like wow you
guys are really [ __ ] up
yeah a lot of these a lot of these
people do procreate and you realize like
wow you know [ __ ] oh man so
there it is
um who would have seen that come in
uh moving on
we've got the Jon Stewart owning the
Arkansas's attorney general do we like
this one there was an update to this
story I haven't seen it so I'm excited
everyone's been talking about you
haven't watched it no
oh well fantastic let's watch it I
thought it was great this is the first
off it was the first ever you know I am
I am a fan of his show it's pretty good
I think on Apple TV this was a really
good
um the only thing I don't like is he
does these round tables and I just
[ __ ] hate Round Table conversations
but no I I think he's
um I don't know I mean I I grew up with
Jon Stewart he's very formative I'll
admit like back then uh I I think what
he was doing was incredible especially
for someone like myself I was like damn
no one is actually talking about no one
is actually criticizing like American
imperialism or no one's actually
criticizing America in this way
uh and and there was a reason why he was
considered one of like the most valuable
news broadcast even though it was on
Comedy Central
um but now I feel like his
like he has his personal uh pet projects
that he truly cares about which is great
and wonderful you know he's always he
was always ride or die for the First
Responders
um you know he's been working on the
burn pitch thing too
but uh other than that I feel like his
commentary unfortunately comes across a
little dull at a time when
you know when when systemic issues are
are way more apparent
you know and he's not really undermining
the root cause and he tries to always
fall into that trap of of fixing
uh the the capitalist structure from
within with capitalist Solutions
but anyway let's let's see this was
probably good though some of his
previous episodes were a little
toothless but this one he really hit uh
really hit hard actually I'm gonna try
to find a longer clip because this one's
only a minute long and I'm not sure
Jon Stewart Jon Stewart was his No Holds
Barred approach for the most part to
certain things now looking back at some
of his commentary I really I recognize
that yes even for back then it wasn't
you know as
as Cutting Edge as I thought it was but
you know I still hold a special place in
my heart
well you're gonna love this this is this
is very good so the background on this
is
she's the attorney general for Arkansas
and they've passed a law
Arkansas
Arkansas and what now I'm so confused
why does it say our Kansas here this is
it is Arkansas
that's how that's her last name bro
I was like what am I looking at no I I
say Arkansas I saw Kansas no I say
Arkansas is a joke that's it's it's but
that's her [ __ ] name wait no no
no that's how you write Arkansas Ethan
are you kidding me only in Kansas City
Arkansas I got another one I think I
know I know it's not your fault
[Music]
and I looked at this and then I started
well English is weird English is weird
it's not no you [ __ ] me bro no I got
you I got you Ethan you know what it is
it's because Jake Paul said it on the
show before it was a meme when he said
Arkansas
too yeah I got it oh what the [ __ ]
that's my shtick anyway so the Attorney
General of Arkansas they're passing
along I said it right and then y'all
started [ __ ] with me I am just like I
have always I've always done this
because lexic okay it's a double whammy
I like to make fun of the state and just
as I make fun of every [ __ ] state
and also
um I I like to make fun of the English
language being so [ __ ] weird where
it's not um
what's the what's the term there's a
specific term for it you can't like
sound you can't sound out the English
language or adequately genetic it's not
phonetic yes so
um you know like why is it Arkansas and
not Arkansas
listen guys
I'm dyslexia okay leave me the [ __ ]
alone
um here's the thing so she they passed a
law saying that prohibiting kids under
18 from getting gender affirming care of
any kind
and
um uh Jon Stewart absolutely eviscerates
her for this there's actually an update
to this story as well which is
satisfying we are going to allow these
children to be children and as they are
we want to again encourage them to have
the access to the mental health care
because none of us can imagine whether
it's my daughter or your son any of us
my son came to me in agony
and I knew there was a program that I
could get them into that had positive
effects on their Mental Health
I would swim across rivers and climb
mountains and tunnel through whatever I
needed to get to to save that child's
life and my guess is you do the same and
I truly hope you're never faced with
that decision because I imagine it's
agonizing for the parent yes and it's
agonizing for the child but the fact
that you've removed that option for
people seems antithetical to the values
you profess to a spouse
well again we're going to have like you
know what
that's obviously not doing it justice
let's just pull this up
uh I think the whole thing is really
good should we watch this or you want to
do I mean I'm down I'm down to watch it
if you want to watch it but we got a lot
going on today we got Alex Jones Kanye
West
did you guys upload this whole thing let
me try and does it did it get claimed
uh no leave it on YouTube only the short
clip yeah you didn't check the the whole
thing no yeah I don't know how litigious
Apple Apple TV yeah I mean probably very
look the the point is he's absolutely
correct these guys are brutal the only
difference between This and like the
abortion ban even though it comes from
the same place of like malicious uh uh
you know hurtful oppressive uh policy
making is that it impacts trans people
and uh and not 50 of the population
women
um so there there aren't that many uh
people that advocate for it gender Norms
are uh a a very important part of our
development and the way we understand it
is very rigid so a lot of people have
you know built-in transphobia from the
jump for that reason so when something
is like so boundary breaking as the
existence of trans people which have
historically existed way before Western
civilization and will continue to exist
um you know and and people don't want to
really understand gender as a social
construct they want to keep going about
it they want to keep going about their
lives without recognizing that maybe the
way we understand it is different right
and maybe we were wrong
um so
there are not that many allies for this
cause so you can get away with being as
brutal as possible which you know
Republicans are never going to stop they
will always do that so you know what I
think this is actually a really
important issue because trans advocacy
is so important I mean like you're
saying they're basically the most [ __ ]
minority of people right now and
actually the most high risk to in terms
of like self-harm and stuff if they're
not getting the proper treatment I think
this this segment is so like impactful
and important let's just watch why would
the state of Arkansas step in to
override
parents Physicians
psychiatrists
endocrinologists who have development
what's an endocrinologist it's a
specialist who and that's like your uh
your hormone system okay got it so that
that would be a right on the nose uh
medical expert yeah got it guidelines
why would you override those guidelines
well I think it's important that all of
those Physicians all of those experts
for every single one of them there's an
expert that says we don't need to allow
children to be able to take those
medications that there are many
instances where but you know that's not
true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that
that's not true I don't know do your
[ __ ] research dumbass what the [ __ ]
you don't know that that's true wouldn't
you well I know that there are doctors
and that we had plenty of people come
and testify before our legislature who
said that uh you know we have 98 of the
young people who have gender dysphoria
that they are able to move past that
it was blocked
our stream no not your stream but I just
re-uploaded so I just got blocked I was
just trying to say it's Apple okay let's
not [ __ ] around but but the point is
it's just so stupid it's like the point
is she doesn't know what the [ __ ] she's
talking about I'm promoting your dumb
[ __ ] Show Jon Stewart you idiot well
you know you know it's also roll over it
it's all their faults um yeah the the
the gender dysphoria argument is super
disingenuous uh because like it factors
in anyone that it factors in every
single person like it basically factors
in anyone and everyone right
um and and not everyone that feels
dysphoric as a as a uh as a child uh is
trans so it doesn't factor in uh
exclusive trans people in that
documentation it factors in everyone
assists so the underlying assumption is
that everyone is CIS and then they
experience gender dysphoria it's
disingenuous
um and if you were to look at actual
experts on the subject matter if you
were to look at all the studies
conducted on this you would see that
it's overwhelmingly positive and
de-transitioning across the board is
like a really rare an incredibly rare uh
phenomena and the one thing that they
always misrepresent is that like
actually un irreversible transitioning
there's like a super high Benchmark
within kids that they have to yeah they
have to check off the list and get all
kinds of approvals from doctors and
associations and stuff but the I guess
the one thing I want to say about this
clip is she keeps referring to this
there's other people there's other
doctors there's other Specialists who
say we shouldn't be doing this so
we found out who the experts are that
she is referring to one of them is uh Dr
Patrick leper she's a plastic surgeon
who's allowed her board certification to
expire and she doesn't even practice
surgery anymore she runs a Botox clinics
in a strip mall in Alabama next to a
Pizza Hut
she's never or he's never worked with a
trans patient and has no experience
treating gender dysphoria they quoted
this doctor
well sure in passing Statewide ban I
mean yeah it's disgusting it's so [ __ ]
up there's just quote this is these are
the people that came and testified in
front of their legislature about this
did they be like so tell me
it's the same tactic I mean it's the
same tactic it's the same tactic with
abortion like both are medical
procedures that's where it works
right that uh you should be able to get
freely okay
and uh they will always find like one
random crank Doctor Who's like nah
that's I will go against the scientific
consensus on the matter
and that's all it takes they don't even
need that really they're just patting
the deck like they're gonna because
their their point isn't genuinely you
know saving people's lives or anything
like that
um they are aware that it's just uh
purposely done for cruelty cruelty
against the marginalized community that
they've demonized
um well they're a great scapegoat they
love the school the the the everyone's
trying to go uh trans by the way thank
you for the gifted uh deaf noodles 20
gifted thank you for the gifted
um yeah so that's that's uh the main
purpose behind it and the tactics are
identical
and with respect to trans people it's
like because they make up a smaller a
much smaller percentage of of every
Community uh whether it's because
they're purposely pushed aside whether
because people cannot realize that they
are trans
I got banned yeah I saw bullying and
harassment
that's crazy we're bowling the Attorney
General of Arkansas or Kansas or Kansas
um say that to me again I want to ever
heard that word again but for those
reasons uh it's it's it's difficult to
um it's difficult to combat the the Sea
of hatred let me just say it here real
fast Dr Paul uh hirez is a doctor
affiliated with the hate group Alliance
defending freedom he objects to gender
affirm and care and religious grounds he
doesn't care about trans youth he stated
some children are born in this world to
suffer and die
he said that good doctor he's a doctor
yo some kids are just born to suffer and
die yeah that's it are you Satan you
know what I mean they're giving they're
giving doctors to everybody out here
this guy went this guy went all the way
got his MD doesn't just say [ __ ] he's
the he's the one in Ten dentist that
doesn't recommend Chris right yeah uh
another one is Dr Stephen Levine makes
his entire living on denying trans
people access to gender affirming care
and his testimony referred to trans
people as narcissistic and his practice
of formal conversion therapy on his
patients there's like a whole
it seems like there's an exclusive
little Club of translating freak doctors
that just they get paid to go take the
show on the road yeah there's a there's
an industry for everything yeah and then
finally Dr Mark
uh ragnaris who wrote the infamous new
Ragnarok Arc Arkansas
new family structure paper in 2012 on
same-sex couples and the effect on
children with the terrible methodology
uh he was thoroughly discredited by the
study and has no expertise in the care
of gender dysphoria and trans use so
there it is Statewide legislation based
on four quacks to put a Miley one who
just openly wants children so he's cool
with Chile being born in this world
suffer and die
there it is guys shout out Arkansas
ladies and gentlemen
love love that love that for them
uh I say support trans people
as loudly and and openly uh as as you
can let's talk about Alex Jones this
[ __ ] just got a billion dollars
yeah speaking of speaking of people who
uh you know hate trans people but
actually secretly loves trans people
Alex Jones Alex Jones number one is one
number one Chaser just like Joe Rogan by
the way oh was Joey Joe Rogan apparently
on his like latest uh Pockets were like
Ari shaffir and another dude openly
stated he loves watching uh chicks with
dicks [ __ ] other kids he's like dude
it's less gay it's like a woman with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] another man oh my God
which is pretty funny because it's like
yeah dude you know the the one thing
that's not queer lesbian porn okay it's
certainly not gay
but wow that's so interesting Joe okay
wow that's so many so many like out and
about transposer Chasers so is Joe Rogan
transphobic I don't remember stuff he
said about Joe Rogan made like that's
like one of his you know how Joe Rogan
has like a certain issues that he will
not budge on at all like it was weed for
the longest time which is a good thing
obviously and then uh one of the one of
the issues that he will not budge on is
like trans athletes but that oh yeah has
opened the door up to so much
transphobia
um you know it's already it's still a a
topic that is widely contested no matter
what no matter where you go even though
the main goal is not necessarily to like
uh instill fairness in sports or
anything and it's usually just to be
transphobic which is what we saw very
quickly in all these states that started
off by being like the one 12 year old
trans girl can't [ __ ] go to the swim
meet it's very quickly turned into like
we will kill you if you offer uh you
know HRT to uh to people over the age of
18 you know what I mean like that was
their overarching goal always right so
uh but yeah Joe Joe has this take let's
take a look this is super interesting
but yeah as you were touching on there's
been a number of transphobic
conservatives who have found have been
found with transport and open either in
their browser that happened with uh Nick
Fuentes yeah it happened with uh Alex
Jones so I find that's so interesting to
keep you know you could still be a woman
just keep your [ __ ] have you watched
trans chick with dick porn because it's
pretty great have I not watched it it's
pretty good because you get the dick and
two women yeah but then you're kind of
whacking off to somebody with a dick
yeah that's an issue aren't you always
aren't you watching the guy [ __ ] man
he's gay of porn because you got exactly
[ __ ] a girl bro I'm not gay bro
you're way more gay than me dude I just
don't know I don't look at Dicks when I
jerk off you gay we have to keep our
country gay people I just don't oh God I
love that but I don't understand like
what who
I mean I guess it's personal preference
but like I don't know I I I I need to
see a dick in the porn like that's my
consumption you know what I mean
listen I'm not talking about my porn
habits here today I'm not I'm not as as
bold as these guys to bring that to the
table here but like I I need to I need I
need that so what do you mean you you so
you're saying you don't like lesbian uh
porn it's not my preference
sometimes I'll watch it but it's not my
preference yeah you want to see a dude
have sex with and and you're not and
that doesn't threaten your masculinity
see a man naked no I'm just I'm
imagining myself in that situation for
example when I jerk off Donnie what
about when Steve will do it jerks off
Donnie that is I don't want to even
think about that uh R can sus uh thank
you for the 50 gifted from our Saudi
benefactor Arkansas thank you
oh there it is I can't control my goo
isn't there certain states where
transporn is the highest rated
um or at the top I don't know if it's
top in any states there are some funny
ones in those charts but uh let me see
there is something really deeply
pathological about people that
hate trans people
what does it mean that you hate trans
people but you watch transporn you're a
chaser
that's there's this terminology for it
what is the Chaser
um so chases are people who fetishize
and objectify trans people as like this
exotic thing and that objectification
process obviously uh robs the trans
person of their Humanity so you're like
specifically looking at them as an
object of Fascination an object of
desire and I think because of uh the
transphobic nature of society
a lot of these people feel conflicted
about their own personal uh want and
their Federation so that's the reason
why they're so outwardly anti-trans
usually
I think but there's I feel like there's
something more pathological going on
there where it's like
it's like I think here's here's what I
think
it's so much more commonly
acceptable to be like oh women are on
this scale of uh bisexuality right
of homosexuality
and I think a lot of these dudes I think
it's the same for men to be on this uh
spectrum of sexuality
yeah and men are so afraid of of
admitting that especially these Macho
dudes who probably want dick more than
anyone you know Joe Rogan would if that
man wants a cop and and that's fine
right like you know he likes muscles and
big [ __ ] I mean these guys they love
and you know that more than anyone right
yeah sexuality is on a spectrum and also
on top of that transphobia is at the
intersection of many different forms of
bigotry all the way from misogyny right
all the way down to homophobia right so
like a Bermuda Triangle so that's
precisely why yeah that's precisely why
it's such a vector for hatred
um especially uh within people who
yes who don't want to recognize that
like trans women are women which is
ironic because when they're justifying
their porn consumption they literally do
say it like the only time these dudes
are like no trans women are definitely
women like chill the [ __ ] out what are
you talking about is when they're
talking about their own personal porn
consumption where it's like what do you
mean it's a chick with a [ __ ] like
whatever that that would never extend in
any other uh meaningful capacity to any
other field it's only when it touches
them in in a way or says something about
them they're like well no it's not gay
bro which it isn't technically it isn't
trans women are women so you're watching
lesbian porn which is gay obviously
um like gay in the in the umbrella term
right what happened uh okay sorry still
and I yeah what I think is happening is
Joe Rogan is getting to express his his
bisexual side guys like Joe Rogan they
watch the transporn and they get to
express no because no it's still
straight to watch transform
it's like the whole point is stoop is
stupid as [ __ ] they even put that label
on it but what's interesting is like
he I don't know I feel like they're
they're doing some kind of uh weird uh
mind trick on themselves where they can
they can uh enjoy their homosexual
desires without having but they can
still deny you know there's something
going on there these men they're
pathologies want to kiss it [ __ ] a dude
I felt that note like that by the way
marriage so and as proof of that it's
really incredible I didn't know trans
um was so popular transporn and Maryland
transporn was number one what the [ __ ]
bro and main number one is fisting so so
this this uh was from their the PornHub
uh they released demographics every year
and this is actually specifically uh
relative search porn so I think like
this is term search more often in each
stage when compared to all other states
so there's no so it's not actually the
top category but it just means that
compared to everywhere else Maryland is
that's the place to be foreign
in Texas I like uh there's some weird
ones in here Harley Quinn
specifically Harley Quinn very specific
love that shout out uh anal [ __ ]
love that why are they looking up penis
pump that's an interesting uh that's
such a weird one pantyhose
giantess respect the whole state big
fake Latina Texas
I love them thick Latinas good job New
York hey shout out c-man yeah oh she's
watching so much foot porn
well that's super interesting well there
it is I think it's it's cute when you're
searching dirty talk on PornHub I'll
just I'll say it that's very sweet it's
like it's like the equivalent of typing
boob into Google what's up with Idaho
giantess yeah giants
like uh like the vampire mommy from the
latest Resident Evil franchise Game
Giant Tess yeah whoa the female form of
giant giantess oh a giantess yeah big
ass titties just bury yourself then I
guess
go spelunking in her vagina eh yeah
let's go respect anyway so Joe Rogan uh
watches transport and that's super
interesting you know and further we were
talking about uh [ __ ] what are we
talking about yeah we got so sidetracked
Alex Jones watches transporn
anyway uh Alex Jones should be watching
his pocket that's what he should be
watching yeah that's a segue for you
let's go let's get back to the main
topic at hand here yeah so Alex Jones
uh in his second of three uh defamation
cases he's like the opposite of you in
the in the American court system knock
on wood yeah
you know but he just got a PL an order
of a
965 million which is an amount that
almost just makes you laugh it's like
okay but there it is a billion dollars
and am I right
so at first I was like okay well there's
got to be a punitive cap because in
Connecticut you looked it up you said
there's 50 000 cap on punitive damages
well so I thought it's the same thing
he's on the hook for like four million
in Texas but it turns out after some
analyzing is this I don't know if this
is 100 confirmed at the moment but this
is from The New York Times so the case
okay that's a reputable Source obviously
depending on who you ask right the case
presents the greatest Fighters
New York Times goddamn fake news media
they says the case presents the greatest
Financial Risk to Mr Jones because if he
was found liable of violating uh
Connecticut's unfair trade Practice Act
by using lies about the shooting to sell
products on Infowars there would be no
cap on punitive damages under that law
there is no law that cooks Alex Jones
more perfectly than this one because
that's literally his Revenue model like
he'll be like they're turning the frogs
gay which is why I need to buy my straws
wait what was he selling off Sandy Hook
what like what products could even like
segue off that I don't know uh you know
Y2K supplements the government's killing
babies on their own you know they're
gonna go They're gonna kill your babies
too that's why I need to buy my my Y2K
supplement I don't know that's such a
specific law it's really interesting but
yeah apparently that prevents a cap
which means this man's on the hook for a
full
billion dollars let's go I mean that's
like I'm sure there are ways to uh get
around this because there are so many
different instances where like people
with any kind of wealth have been able
to evade uh you know duck responsibility
and any kind of like punitive damages uh
with basically what is a slap on the
wrist right
um I'm sure you could like shelter some
of your assets if he hasn't done so
already I'm sure he has uh and then and
then get around it
uh they could garnish his wages they
could liquidate all of his assets he's
[ __ ] yeah he's [ __ ] um but the goal
I think ultimately is not to offer some
kind of financial restitution to the
victims but it is to basically show the
rest of the world that this is
completely unacceptable which it was
what Alex Jones did is insanely
unacceptable yeah and and that you know
people should be more careful about uh
creating mass hate campaigns against uh
against people that they've declared uh
you know villains with no actually uh
people whose children were just murdered
yeah the best uh Target there Alex
you think Infowars is done and I mean
there's still another one coming the man
is so [ __ ] financially yeah by the way
during the verdict
he this man was alive on his show
fundraising as one of the parents of the
slain children is crying I mean this is
like I just he's [ __ ] fundraising I
just I can't like it's so strange
because he's so telegenic he's so
charismatic as like a pure Entertainer
but you cannot you cannot uh remove the
the consequences of his actions from
from who the Alex Jones the Entertainer
is like as much as I want to as a long
time Alex Jones fan originally you know
what I mean as someone who was
fascinated by his Persona as someone who
found him to be outright entertaining
it's impossible not to recognize the
genuine harm he has caused in American
society now he's not single-handedly
responsible for this obviously the
systems are are at fault more than
anything else
um but this is complete Insanity
I mean this is this is such Insanity
that it it belongs in a movie right and
I don't mean like a Richard linklater
movie where uh Alex Jones will be
playing himself or a version of himself
I mean like literally this is this is
crazy no this is I agree it's totally
nuts here it is and from Remington
ain't gonna be happening ain't no money
I guess Alex Jones I killed the kids
folks I think
number one compensatory damages
instructions filled in both numbers for
each pointed now remember I'm in
bankruptcy we got two years of appeals
the money you donate does not go to
these people has to fight this fraud and
it goes to stabilize the company they
want to shut down that's why the the the
the the Daniels Chasers did this why
they use these families so save
infowars.com we're fighting Goliath
we'll win because of you saving for
wars.com
infowarstore.com
double Patriot points and then four
store but you see you want somebody to
five for you I'm doing it and you see
what they do so you want we want to
fight that's fine it's your decision
but that's where we are that's the
whacked out system on the left did we
hit a billion guy in from Remington did
we hit a million yet yes so by the way
pretty sure he's committing bankruptcy
fraud right there on TV you can't
fundraise to save the business
while you're bankrupting the business I
think the bankruptcy people are going to
have an invested interest in where all
this money goes I love that he said
those guys are ambulance Chasers have
you seen his lawyer dude he's got a
double ponytail he [ __ ] literally on
in the in the trial straight up said
Alex Jones is a mad prophet and he is
Unstoppable
I mean he's just oh God their lawyers
are definitely not uh ambulance Chasers
the guy who finally sued him put it off
for years and years and years until uh
Alex Jones fans had destroyed
eviscerated any semblance of life that
he could possibly live had absolutely
tap dance on the grave yeah that's the
that's his lawyer that's how it shows
his lawyer
that's my lawyer dog I'm going to prison
on a defamation trial
he's I mean
it's so gross I mean it's so evil and so
[ __ ] gross but Alex Jones in many
cases is just ungovernable you know
two for two on defaming the judge on the
awards uh declaration trial
two for two he did it in Texas he
defamed the judge while the proceedings
were going on he defamed the judge in
Connecticut too he did what do you say
about them I think he did the same thing
with the laser eyes and [ __ ]
he didn't go as hard on the Connecticut
judge but he definitely went super hard
on the Texas judge yeah I know I
remember it was crazy
but uh all the worst things to Alex
Jones I'm super excited to watch this
guy's life uh go down the drain wish
nothing but the worst for him and uh I
hope that uh Infowars go offline forever
you know what's really interesting about
this also is that I've always maintained
the belief that like no one is truly a
free speech absolutely like maybe some
exceptions right
um and this is one of those perfect
instances right like you can't yell fire
in a crowded theater and like defamation
does not fall under Free Speech right
and not only do we all know that but
this is a clear-cut instance of
defamation
um with ongoing harassment that has
occurred after that but so many
right-wing conservatives came out in
defense of Alex Jones saying like the
regime The Establishment wants to take
him down for speaking truth to power or
whatever which is by the way like What
dunking on the the victims yeah the
families of like Sandy Hook victims like
that's crazy
um
but all of those people have personally
consistently been like you have defamed
me good sir I will be seeing you in
court like they all have defamation
tweets of their own so they all
obviously recognize it uh that
defamation does not fall under that
super broad uh uh protection that Free
Speech offers
yeah I mean crazy stuff everyone who's
threatened to sue me or has to me I'm
pretty sure it's Maga I don't know about
Matt Haas I think he's mag about I don't
know
but yeah I mean
yeah they love that they love hitting
people with defamation suits while
simultaneously screaming that Alex Jones
should have been protected
so uh he's got one more trial coming up
um which state is that in do you know
no I don't no but I mean he's already a
billion down so I mean what what does it
matter at this point it's gonna have a
lot of creditors there a lot of debtors
uh Mr Jones has a third Sandy Hook
damages trial pending
uh you lost to these two families I
don't know where it is though
but anyway so uh Alex Jones ladies and
gentlemen moving on now to Kanye West
who's just come out as a straight up
anti-semite yeah well Ben Shapiro Ben
Shapiro thinks otherwise I mean he did
say it's anti-semitic what he said but
yeah but he even like casts a little bit
of Doubt on it while simultaneously
saying that Kaya was was saying
anti-semitic things like deathcon 3 on
all Jews
insanity
but I didn't know Benny boy was
defending he's not he's not really
defending he was defending the abortion
stuff that he was talking about he's
like well you know bipolar disorder he
like went on an in-depth analysis on
like bipolar disorder and how it uh you
know how that could be a factor in why
he's saying anti-semitic things but
certainly not a factor in in what he's
saying uh otherwise like all the other
conservative stuff that he's mentioning
um he literally did that well you know
he's neurodivergent
yeah I mean I used to be like man he's
just not well and that I mean that
that's not he's not but at a certain
point you go well does being bipolar
make you anti-semitic does being bipolar
make you hate Jews my beautiful day
that's a simple fantasy no but being
bipolar will open you up to you're more
vulnerable to probably outside
influences that uh that will take
advantage of you and you know uh put
some books your way that uh you you do
not have the the mental fortitude to
assess adequately and then you start
believing some of the [ __ ] that you hear
and then in a manic episode you just
blurt it all out because you are such a
gigantic narcissist surrounded by
sycophants that have pushed and you've
pushed away everyone in your circles
that could actually check you so you
just think uh any kind of pushback
against what you're saying is completely
ridiculous
and uh you turn into this to this
behemoth
Ian what are your thoughts on the Kanye
West black Israelite narrative
he's not there he's not there but
someone's switching
yeah
again Ian's a huge cognac fan it's been
a hard a couple of years for him yeah
maybe it's better to say was he was he
was he was yes we wrote a screenplay
about no way no he was in look I I like
Kanye West is he graduation is great
like I I I like I like his music in the
words of kaios himself you know I like
kiowa's music what the [ __ ] does he know
about politics okay
you know it's just it's obvious and by
the way I I've actually talked about
this a little bit more in depth in the
past I didn't have the Liberty to
discuss such things at at the time
because I didn't want to like out any of
my friends but like I knew that his trip
to Uganda was like a very uh tumultuous
and and almost like attorney represented
a turning point uh in his experience
overall because I I had heard that he
was uh getting really into the black
Israelite stuff and even saying things
that were anti-semitic in nature in in
private
um and then it came out that even in
2018 when he had that uh conversation
with uh Harvey Levin at TMZ that he had
actually said some things about Hitler
and shout out yeah he gave a shout out
to Adolf Hitler like he's a shout out to
Hitler yeah Big Ups
um let's go through we've got we've
basically got it all charted out but all
right we're we're like Alex is part of
the Saga start like Alex Jones you know
he's causing a lot of harm uh and and
you know but so let's see
um Kanye let's see if this whole Saga
started out at Paris Paris fashion week
he was wearing a white lives matter
shirt uh oh side Candace Owen Ben
Shapiro employee Candace Owen yeah
and here is that so this obviously
caused quite a stir for uh obvious
reasons
and
and then his reaction to that was if
anyone asked me like why I'm wearing a
white lives matter shirt it's because
they do
you know cool dude
nobody said they don't but I've already
I mean we've already talked about this a
billion times it's literally just
provocative
uh
and then P Diddy apparently reached out
to Kanye trying to talk to him about all
this and Kanye flipped on him said he
was being controlled by Jews and posted
screenshots of their text this was very
interesting to see the Jews
so here let's see
so this is a text that Kanye sent Puff
Daddy I don't like our combo I'm selling
these teas nobody so is he selling White
lives matter tease I guess I mean
it's pretty I think he has yeah
saying that he will I mean yeah it's not
that I mean you know
it's kind of [ __ ] you buy off of you
know hog.com where we got all of our
little Mega shirts it's not that fashion
forward just saying message aside he
says I'm selling these teas nobody gets
it between me and my money
this is my grandfather texting you now
never call me with no [ __ ] like that
again unless you're ready to Green Light
me because nobody who got on that
anybody who got on that t is me
uh out of respect for everything you've
meant to me I'll be quiet as Virgil but
no now I know how I've hurt people I
love with threats come do something
illegal to me now please
yeah so he posted I said God is love my
brother misspoke to me but I still love
him the thing that drives me crazy is
how many enablers Kanye has but okay
he's so popular what do you expect yeah
uh he continues you want to go ahead
uh Diddy says I'm just trying to talk to
you as a black man and I'm talking to
you because this is hurting our people
stop you say anything you text I will
post I love you and you guys are
breaking my heart I accept your apology
in advance
say God is love and then did he said N
word send me an address let's stop
playing these internet games and and
don't feel threatened you'll be fine
just love he said this ain't a game imma
use you as an example to show the Jewish
people that told you to call me that no
one can threaten or influence me I told
you this was war now go and get you some
business
uh so he's implying there that uh Diddy
is controlled by Jews as you know and
the and and you know and the Jews are
making him do this now there's two
separate sides to this though because he
will underneath this in the caption what
does he say if you scroll down he says
Jesus is Jew and then there are
instances where he has said like black
people are the real Jews uh
but you know what I say about this what
you can be the Jew bro I I don't care
you know what I mean okay listen
I don't want to deal with this [ __ ]
you're washing your hands take it be the
jewel what the [ __ ] do I care I don't
need this okay oh you're watching you
this life I didn't ask for it you're
washing your hands about any of this
[ __ ] be the Jew Kanye you want to be the
Beast juice about take it bro you want
to see what it's like it's not that
[ __ ] dope bro whatever you think it
is just go be it enjoy it man take it
from me not trying to do any [ __ ] to you
bro Ethan said have fun with IBS
you want to have tummy aches every time
you eat frozen pizza Kanye take that
[ __ ] you want that
roses
uh so he said he continues on uh here
did he says as soon as I land we'll meet
face to face send me an address he said
n-word [ __ ] you you fed the n-word I
gotta say puff is kind of a badass
well I mean yeah he's may or may not
have killed people allegedly so
big Puff Daddy it's been a long you
don't remember that he was involved in
the death of uh Tupac yeah you don't
know the Tupac that was all uh some
other dude and there was there was like
someone who claimed that it was Diddy
nah Diddy would never do that Diddy's a
good man
he is he's a good man you know that's
interesting okay uh Daddy's a good man
you follow him on Instagram he's got
Vibes bro he does have fun for sure
um anyway so all of this happened but I
love how he goes send me your dress dude
you'll be fine well I don't think he was
gonna kill him I think he was just
trying to have a conversation with him
face to face and be like bro what the
[ __ ] are you doing you're out of your
mind yeah because like in certain
instances when someone's going through
like a manic episode one of the best
things you could do is pay you know try
to maybe reason with them face to face
because over the Internet it just uh or
over text messages it just doesn't have
that same impact you know yeah so but I
think the standout thing was just about
the he's being controlled by Jews which
of course is one of the great
anti-semitic tropes yeah of of our day
and so I think he got
um suspended on Instagram after that one
and then of course which is of course a
[ __ ] I mean come on come on well
it's free speech baby
I thought you I'll tell you who you just
saying oh God
that is unironically what the Nazis say
by the way right record
um actually absolutely there is a really
funny thing he tweeted out after he got
banned oh yeah on on Twitter you mean
photos of them doing karaoke yeah he's
like I love dogs how did you ban me
yeah because you [ __ ] with the Jews
brother yeah so he did that and then uh
and then he went on Tucker Carlson yeah
so that's that that's my favorite thing
he gets banned for being anti-semitic on
Instagram and then Tucker's like let's
talk yeah so everyone is like riding him
now all the conservatives are like Kanye
West is prolific brilliant you know
everyone that literally said
rap music is not real music that's right
everyone that has made a career [ __ ]
on black people as a whole all of a
sudden are big Kanye stands they they
came out and they're like oh man I love
Connor always love Kanye yeah always
been a big fan right
um you know what George Bush does hate
black people yeah so he so he goes on
Tucker Carlson they have insane
conversations that are
basically very trumpian uh you know
talking about like all these media
people that I I love imagining 70 year
olds from Arkansas watching and not
comprehending they're like who what he
he was denied the cover of Vogue what
the [ __ ] you know what I mean stuff like
that outrageous yeah also he looks like
he's in a Sith
I do like the beard I really thought
beardier super dark I I thought beardier
was going to be different because he he
looks cool he looked you like it I I do
I agree I think it's a good look for him
you would say that
yeah the Jew and me no that's not what
I'm talking about no I was talking about
him talk I was talking about the beard
me saying that it's yeah yeah beard
solidarity is still on so here's Tucker
yeah as soon as someone gets banned on
social media for being racist or
anti-semitic Tucker's like come on this
show I want to advocate for you
for a minute and there's a photograph on
it what is that it's a photograph of a
baby's ultrasound
why is that and that you designed that
yes why what does that mean it just
represents life from pro-life
boy so you wear it on a badge what what
kind of response do you get and good
amen I agree I don't care about people's
responses I care about the fact that
there's more
black babies being aborted than born in
New York City that can't be true can it
there's no [ __ ] I heard that I was
like there's no shot there's more
abortions than births
of black babies
not that it matters one way or the other
because they're not babies they're it's
an abortion it just seems like it can't
be true
so
um I mean he's tarnishing his own legacy
as as uh
you know an important uh artist in this
space
but that's whatever uh but also he's
doing it in the worst way imaginable
where he's he's writing for some of the
worst ideas
and it's corny as [ __ ] too on top of
everything else
um you know at least Michael Jordan was
like conservatives by shoes too but he
didn't go boss to the wall on it you
know what I mean he wasn't like he
wasn't talking about like the great
replacement or some [ __ ] yeah I mean
he's just bit he's just really [ __ ]
himself out to White supremacists it's
kind of interesting really yeah um
there's turns out there's more to it
though the a lot of the parts of this
interview that were especially crazy
were cut out including
including but not limited to uh Kanye
West talking about how uh you know black
people are the real Jews
uh from this Tucker Carlson interview
which is interesting I wonder why they
cut that out I mean Tucker Carlson said
he's a free speech guy but
apparently they also not apparently they
did also cut out him saying he's
vaccinated
yeah that was weird as well yeah he did
say that he was vaccinated uh they cut
out certain parts where he's talking
about uh you know there's these actors
in his house that are around his
children
um and and he doesn't know where the
these actors came from I mean paranoid
hallucinations are a part of uh I think
a part of like manic breakdowns
oftentimes but you know conservatives do
love uh someone going through an episode
as long as they can weaponize it for
their cause
so that's not it's not new or surprising
or unique to to Kanye West by the way
what I'm seeing is in 2019 there was
more births of black babies than
abortions
yeah according to this Newsweek article
because they fact checked all this they
said uh that was the case in 2019 which
I'm assuming is the most recent data
that's available Newsweek also checked
previous years datum found that more
black women gave birth than had
terminations in 2017 and 18 uh but in
2016 there were slightly more uh
abortions than births amongst black
women so that is I mean it it did happen
at one point but that is a far-fetch of
a claim it's not completely far-fetched
yeah at this point that 50 of Black
Death
in America is abortion so I really don't
care about people's responses I perform
for audience of one and that's God
yeah
they love that conservatives love that
one so they're they're championing him
and then it comes out that he has said a
lot more
and then he also tweets that he was good
to go def con Defcon 3 on uh Jews yes
which gets him suspended off Twitter
I've got the whole timeline here uh with
Eclipse Kanye this so basically they
aired the PG version this is I don't
know how this stuff leaked but this one
was so fun here's [ __ ] that they cut
that later got leaked device
here he is saying he just watched bro
yeah this one's yeah
I was biting my tongue on my political
opinion because I thought it would be
better for my children and now you look
up and my kids are going to a school
that teaches black kids a complicated
Kwanzaa
I prefer my kids new Hanukkah than
Kwanzaa at least it will come with some
Financial engineering
doesn't you know so oh that's Trump
that's literally Trump
the Fouseytube uh I have heard Trump say
identical [ __ ] you know he'll go to like
uh like an American Jews uh fundraiser
right like like American Jews for
Israeli Freedom fundraiser or whatever
the [ __ ] and he'll be like you know you
guys are so good with money yeah yeah
you guys know
yours what does he mean though like
because there's like I guess
traditionally in Hanukkah you play with
like uh what no what are your coins no
why are you I'm trying to rationalize it
no you're trying to you're trying to
look further no he's just saying Jews
are good with money so so by celebrating
Hanukkah his kids will be better with
money yeah unlike Kwanzaa the broke ass
lameo religion I don't know anything
about Kwanzaa for the record yeah well
you didn't go to the schools that
Kanye's children went to though but
still he makes it very clear that
Hanukkah is also a [ __ ] I uh I went
to the school where his kids go
what you did yeah I went to sear Canyon
did you learn about
um we did actually yeah okay yeah wow
that explains a lot
did you learn about Hanukkah we did we
learned about Christmas so so okay I
mean I might have changed from when I
was there seems like he just wants to to
lessen the CR the curriculum yeah but
that's but that's the funny that's the
the funnier uh kind of bigotry where
he's like you know the Jews controlled
the banking institutions but they're
doing a good job they're doing a good
job with it
so make them angry
so yeah he he said that
um which is again another anti-semitic
trope
uh yeah I mean when you look at Hitler's
rationale for like the final solution it
all ties back to these high level
insane Jewish conspiracies you know and
this stuff all feeds into that when
you're willing to accept that Jews as a
minority group have this ungodly amount
of influence or coordinated influence
over all these huge walks of life and
the the rant about Planned Parenthood
here which is the third one on the
docket uh that one is where he like says
black people are the real Jews uh go for
it bro take it uh you want to pull that
well let's watch this one I got this one
up right oh the energy communities yeah
yeah this one's just crazy this one I
don't know why they cut it I think that
people would really drive with this I'll
talk to him if I see him yep
but I guarantee you he see me
and
he's talking about Obama there visions
that God gives me I'm not just over and
over on community building and how to
build these
free energy
kinetic fully kinetic energy
communities where we impress we we put
the least impression on the earth we're
not building the the new New York
skyline cockfight that
we are humble
in the way that we present ourselves
we've got to rethink who we are as a
species
Tuckers are right on board with you oh
um but sure for sure Tucker Carlson had
like a like a raw egg nationalist or
something the other day on his broadcast
where like he loves that [ __ ] that
Tucker also famously an advocate for
ball tanning right little ball tanning
and the return of masculinity stuff he's
big into that like self-help you know
goop for white nationalist males uh
Jason I wonder if Tucker would put a
jade egg up his ass yeah you told him it
gave him more testosterone so there was
that and then there's the pawn yeah the
real Jews comment let's see Planned
Parenthood was made by Margaret Sanger
a known Eugenics with the KKK
to control
the Jew population when I say Jew I mean
the 12 lost tribes of Judah the blood of
Christ who
the race the people known as the race
black Billy are you know what's crazy
about how they're using Kanye as like a
useful idiot you know the moment he left
Tucker was like that guy's [ __ ]
insane oh yeah lunatic and then they air
it like hey look at this guy we love
Kanye he's the best yeah that's why they
cut out the parts where he's going you
know bananas mode that's literally what
it means yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] hates Kanye
he thinks he's a freak well yeah Tucker
doesn't he's not too fond of black
people in general unless he can use them
as a token to weaponize sometimes
against the black community and uh
sometimes against everyone else anyone
yeah anyone people known as the raised
black really are this is who our people
are the blood of Christ this as a
Christian is my belief and I believe
that if we saw ourselves as more
just so what is it I don't understand
this whole
uh it's it's for the real Jews it's a
black Israelite Theory uh yeah so they
claim that like uh all the white Jews
like all the other Jews are are actually
fake Jews and they are the real Jews so
they also have some really cool ideas
like Shakespeare was black
uh right on uh Cleopatra not black uh
but uh who else is black like Mozart
Beethoven black oh sick yeah my heart
definitely wasn't black now how dare you
say that I'm sorry about that um but I
mean they got they got crazy drip they
dress up like Mortal Kombat characters
uh which I think German or Austrian or
some [ __ ]
yeah but black regardless where is that
I mean it come look if you want to dive
deeper into it it comes from you know
generational trauma and and trying to
uh instead of address that the psychic
damage that causes an entire community
of people 400 years of slavery is
nothing to just cast aside uh no matter
how much uh you know white supremacists
try to do that uh it's it's
a a group of people that want to not
face that reality and and you know make
material restitution or fight for
material restitution but instead uh you
know look for alternative uh history
buildings so that that never actually
happened in your mind so
how is it anti-semitic they say that
Jews modern day Jews are like
intentionally misleading like I know I'm
not the real Jew like someone like me is
in on this
yeah I mean it's not that you're the
expert I don't know I'm just trying to
no I mean I I know a little bit but like
am I and they're I in their head am I in
on this conspiracy someone like me who's
like just totally every every Jewish
person like every Jewish person is is uh
I guess secretly in on it I mean it's
always the same with Jews right it's
like every every conspiracy theory
ultimately needs a villain because it's
it's just and you know what man from
materialist analysis so they have to
find like a nefarious reason as to why
people do these kinds of things in a
shadowy room right and and that's the
reason why since the blood libel day
since the original sin since all of that
even before that really uh that uh a
group of individuals were held
responsible for no reason uh and and
that group of individuals has always
been Jews right doing every good
conspiracy theory blames the Jews yeah
even [ __ ] inoculation like Flat Earth
or conspiracy theories made earth flat
yeah NASA is like controlled by Jews
like every everything that's what I'm
saying Kanye be the Jew bro
I don't want to be the Jew you'd be the
Jew what the [ __ ] I don't want to deal
with this [ __ ] I'd love to just be like
a [ __ ] normal dude you don't have to
talk about me being Jewish yeah Jews did
911 all that fun stuff bro just leave me
alone you do all that [ __ ] man please
with my blessings you're the black
Israelite God bless man I'm bowing out
you're right you're right so he's saying
that
um I'm bowing out but black Israelites
for the most part are just like they're
annoying you know what I mean they just
don't they don't really have any sort of
uh genuine power in any meaningful
capacity they're just like kind of the
dudes that you see at the subway station
uh looking like Mortal Kombat characters
yelling at everybody about how they're
like fake Jews and stuff right
um
so I mean I I find it interesting
partially because it's like uh
it doesn't have any sort of like
systemic harm that it is capable of
causing
um even though black Israel are
responsible for uh some hate crimes
against like Jewish schools and whatnot
there was a case in New Jersey and one
in New York where there was uh an
anti-semitic attack that occurred wanted
a Jewish Delhi I believe and wanted a
school if not exactly man yeah that's
way more that's a place of worship I was
going to say that's more sacred than the
synagogue you [ __ ] beast you animal
yeah so so that has happened in the past
as well but other than that like other
than uh
uh individual acts of of uh individual
acts of anti-Semitic violence there is
no like broader systemic structure that
it hinges on because it's a it's a small
group of people that do not have any
sort of uh legitimate power there's no
like secret there's no there's no
societal development that is built upon
uh I'm ready Black Hebrew Israelite
conspiracy theories in the same way that
like white supremacy has been built upon
I'm ready
if they need a ceremony if we need to
make this official I don't know what
they want if there's any black
Israelites watching
I can pass off the credentials you want
me to hand you a Torah or something
you're right bro take it I don't want it
can I give can I one Jew give another
black Israelite my Jew like I Jew make
you Jew now you know doing your works
that way I'm sorry to report I just I
don't want it get together in a yeah
get together in one of the meetings and
you can discuss it I guess with the
Elder counselor
um being being a Jew is [ __ ] annoying
well 99 of the time it's like why y'all
[ __ ] care so much
like the everybody every story needs a
villain and historically uh it's always
been Jews like unjustifiably of course
but it it it's just uh it's an old Trope
that they like to to go back to they get
comfort from it I guess
yeah all comfortable anti-Semitism yeah
so like being home uh here is more
anti-semitic it's our culture is based
on think about us judging each other on
how white we could talk would be like
you know
a Jewish person judging another Jewish
person on how good they danced
or something I mean that's probably like
a bad example of people gonna get mad at
that [ __ ] but
uh
that was a weird one another thing that
they do
uh I was going to ask what you guys
think like is the implication like
Jewish people are bad at dancing
or like they shouldn't be dancing at all
like he's talking about black people
codes code switching in order is a
mechanism of survival in a in a white
supremacist society and then he turns
around and he's like and Jews can't
dance right no more dancing at bar
mitzvahs man yeah I don't know why maybe
what the [ __ ] you want about Jews with
those guys those guys shred man yeah I
was about to say like maybe he saw maybe
he saw the [ __ ] the the like the
Hasidic uh
Jews getting down at bar mitzvahs and
[ __ ] to Waka Flocka you know yeah yeah
yeah they do the mashup
um here let's continue on
I probably want to edit that out in
front and I'd like that I like that that
was like that's
wow okay edit out the Jews Jews are
actually dope at dance yeah they dance
fine yeah he corrected himself
because he had the logic there with like
by the way equating it to like you said
code switching so it's like a Jew
dancing is a Jew code switching to being
not Jewish it's very strange [ __ ] Kanye
watch your mouth [ __ ] I wish you played
the music for like one second it's a
party
hey
juice [ __ ] dance so hard
at that there's that video in Israel
where they literally the second yeah
story building and like 70 people crazy
with it yeah man
that's how we do it maybe he saw that
live fast die hard you know what I mean
[Music]
check this out
yo Kanye be talking mad [ __ ]
where are you at now [ __ ]
where you at you ain't here Kanye you
ain't on this level [ __ ]
put that [ __ ] uh that drip goes crazy
next up next merch for Kanye Kanye
should just do black Israelite merge
honestly yeah I mean he's not that far
off at this point yo doing that tip dude
put that little middle foot in take that
middle foot out shut up dude
we call it the gefilte Pokey yeah this
is basically like a high level doci
though
yeah you know what I mean
yeah eat your words [ __ ] anyway
um
more
Okay so
you know I was talking to Ice Cube Today
and we got really beat up in 2020 for
saying we need to approach things a
different way and not just be trauma
drunk right which is a term that I you
know God just hit me with in the past
couple days we are no longer trauma
drunk
we are no longer trauma drunk and we're
no longer trauma bonding and we're no
longer woke in the sense of what woke is
because woke is just complaining about
racism but not doing anything about it
so yeah
what was complaining about reason but
not really doing anything about it but
also like
you know who complains the most
[ __ ] who say White lives matter
at least people who say black lives
matter have like a legitimate cause a
legitimate movement the organization
itself might be a completely fraudulent
right but it's a real thing that uh that
people are genuinely upset by it's a a
white supremacist Criminal Justice
System uh and and Kanye West is like
yeah you guys aren't doing anything
about it so I decided to go and use the
counter movement that White's premises
came up with uh and and ride that dude
you're a billionaire one of the you're
in a position to do something about it
and what are you doing about it you're
telling other people to stop whining
like [ __ ] you
dude such a useful idiot you've become
what we're going to do about it is say
hey you know what
y'all not gonna send nobody at me what
do we do about it
based on my opinion
you asked the question before
it drove me crazy to not be able to say
that I like Trump
thank you said it all right no but that
that personally kind of showcases where
this like reactionary rhetoric comes
from though a guy who's never been told
no for a very long time who can't who
does not know how to handle it getting
told no at uh you know at this large
this wide enough scale looking
desperately for any kind of Ally that
will take them and say no what you're
doing is right keep going Kanye and just
uh you know going off on crazy tangents
he's basically stating it there is no
interpretation there's no analysis
there's no like genuine political
interest in any of the movements that
he's like uh signing off on or
criticizing really it's just how it
impacted him how it impacted Kanye West
it drove him crazy uh that he couldn't
say he loves Trump uh you know it's it's
a perfect uh uh it's a it's a
perfect powder keg of of narcissism
bipolar disorder and uh and and just
being like a petulant little child uh
when people tell you no you're like no I
have to keep going I have to be more
contrarian right uh this is what my
favorite cut personally uh
ask yourself why did they cut this I
don't know you know every day we've been
killing each other
in the streets
every day one of the amazing things with
mayor Suarez is
the the murder rate has gone down and
yeah I don't I mean you set that
question up you have more information
about the uh
about the uh about what happened in the
hospitals so in all honesty I don't I
don't have the the most facts as
manufacturing I mean in your life like
somebody
vaccine the being stuck inside like what
did you think of all that I was I was
vaccinated it was they cut this [ __ ]
because it's so they want them to be as
palatable as they can to their white
premises audience and at the same time
with open disdain for actually who Kanye
is by by cutting out
uh his comments
uh because they know he's he's crazy
yeah last night he was at the uh the the
the red carpet with the Kid Rock Ray J
for the Candace Owens like documentary
the big lie or something yeah I got that
coming up in here
anyway he said yeah this was the this
was the fire tweet yeah this one set it
off he says I'm a bit sleepy tonight but
when I wake up I love that I'll be going
def con three on all caps Jewish people
in like eight spaces in between wait
hold the [ __ ] phone bro that was on
the 8th the ninth was was deathcon 3
Jewish Day what did he ever go death
gone no because because fake Twitter
suspended him before he could go
I kind of wanted to see where it would
go thank you I wanted so bad I wanted to
know what he he had to say so bad he's a
coward put it on a website people will
see it you know I mean go to rumble
whatever the [ __ ] yeah I know I think he
likes being able to have got a parlor
account or something no well you know I
woke up on I I may he may have gone
death con three of me because I woke up
the next day super sick out of nowhere
they activated the kill grid [ __ ] and he
said the funny thing is a 5G Krill grid
has been flipped on black people are
actually Jew also of actually Jew you
guys have toyed with me and tried to
blackball anyone whoever opposes your
agenda again bro I think he also try to
say like who created cancer culture like
implying lightly that it was the Jews
Maybe
yeah that was definitely I mean there's
been the first people to be canceled
let's be real yeah if anything they you
know what I mean cancel more than
anybody else [ __ ] uh but yeah Candice
Owens had a wonderful three-minute
defense of this where she said uh some
some cool things that I'll be
paraphrasing like what does deathcon
mean maybe he meant uh he wanted to
defend the all Jewish people because
Defcon is technically about defense I've
got that here if you want to watch the
video no let's watch it it's because
it's really good uh after this tweet
as you touched on the TMZ guy uh van
Lathan said on his podcast that during
that great TMZ that guy I watched go
back and watch that clip he was he
absolutely eviscerated Connie it was
really something yeah but he said
something to the effect of I love Hitler
I love Nazis that they cut out
uh shame they cut that out that would
have been a great sound bite but uh
here is uh Ian can I say this Ian can I
share this yeah so Ian says this is why
he's no longer associating with Kanye
fandom uh I'm pretty certain these are
different sentences he's questioning how
the reason for the IG band is him being
anti-Semitic
he was literally on interview praising
Jews on Fox just two days ago what no I
I saw this a couple times where people
were trying to be like no he's saying
I'm gonna wake up and go death con 3.
anyway on Jewish people right anyways on
Jewish people like a separate it's a new
chapter that's the title of the next
chapter it's just funny because she's
trying to be like no I hate Jewish
people I want you all to know I'm gonna
speak my truth in my heart right now I
hate Jewish people and they're like no
no no no no that's not what he means he
was what he means that's basically what
Canada's Owens did literally and like
death con three he's probably trying to
defend the Jews if anything oh no uh she
also said if anything he's asking
questions and trying to drive discourse
right and it's like yeah she was
basically like a Jewish question uh if
anything that's a question let's talk
about that deserves answers you know
let's talk about it it's just a
conversation what do we do about it
Final Solution what if the solution is
uh that uh you know we we praise uh
Jewish people how about that that was
the Final Solution that's the solution
thank them they're not shocking coming
from of course uh Candace uh Hitler
wanted to make Germany great uh Owen it
Hitler was Maga yeah she did say she did
say that
um that was fine everyone
um
Ian I'm not trying to do stick here I'm
just genuinely curious what is the Kanye
Community like these days or like I
remember you went on that Kanye podcast
where those guys were like super
hardcore yeah do you know anything about
like the state of his community right
now
uh yeah those guys are fully Conan on
yeah really they're still in it yeah a
lot of Defense they responded to
uh the thing about him saying that he
loves Hitler being like Kanye was at the
time he was saying he loves everyone he
was trying to pre preach this like
love your name Universal love okay and
they're they're on they're actively
doing this even now what about Defcon 3
on Jewish people
just that it was wrong syntax bro if
they're [ __ ] defending Kanye saying
he loves Hitler I'm pretty sure the
Defcon yeah that didn't bother it's like
much easier to defend than that it's
just funny that they're they're not on
board with it they're just they're so
desperate he's like bro yo I want you
all to know right now I hate Jewish
people like how much more clear can I
make it that's awesome yeah I think a
lot of his fans are kind of out but
there's still a bunch of die hards in
there and it's kind of embarrassing the
way that they have to try and spin it
like it's okay you don't have to agree
with everything he does all right we're
gonna separate the r from the artist
yeah
well so um oh is this a post on uh the
Kanye subreddit yeah I know there's
there's definitely internal drama in the
Kanye subreddit but apparently uh what
is it the West ever West sub ever it's
called West sub ever is the one that's
like dick riding him super hard oh my
God yeah embarrassing oh Candace Owens
also said uh [ __ ] inner defense she also
says something along the lines of like
well it's not like Kanye is is you know
trying to directly kill Jewish people
like not directly literally she
literally made it seem like the only
time you could be anti-semitic is if
you're quite literally doing the holiday
if you're not putting a gun to Jewish
people's heads and pulling the trigger
how can you be anti-semitic which by the
way is very famously the same thing that
White supremacists say about like racist
people we're like oh well he didn't
literally say the n-word or if he did
say the n-word uh you know well what if
he meant it like uh you know when you're
reading Tom Sawyer like there's always a
defense for it I'm using the n-word in
like the skull dollarly way yeah using
the N word but I'm not lynching anyone
yeah I mean that's uh that's usually the
the argument it's the news so Candace
Owen uh his new bestie there go around
with their white lives
matter shirts apparently Kanye was asked
to leave Chase Bank which I kind of I
find that kind of funny they just closed
his account that is insane that's the
Jewish conspiracy that that is okay so I
but that is insane I have some more info
about that like let's work with [ __ ]
drug traffickers and [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
okay what's the Intel yeah apparently he
had been trying to terminate his
relationship with that bank for the last
few months
um and he even talked about that
publicly and we didn't cover it in it
but apparently in when he was popping
off about everybody he
um he was like also calling out specific
employees at the bank
um as part of like his Rants and like uh
you know higher ups in the bank and they
were like getting threats from his fans
and stuff uh so they were like you know
what we're out so and so on so it was a
conspiracy I mean the timing is
unfortunate because yeah a guy saying
hey Jews uh control the world and then a
bank dropping him are you sure this is
not a great look still yeah probably or
we'll find fact check that maybe uh
let's see it's JP Morgan
conspiracy I think because she's like
there's no reason there's no way that
this would happen all the sudden by the
way in there oh no he's Greek oh he's
Greek he's Greek well thank God
think now Hassan's upset now though
oh my God you guys typical Greek
Behavior hold on hold on Facebook says
his wife is Jewish oh there it is his
wife there it is his children that means
his children are Jews his wife is Jewish
and he has Jewish kids all right that
means the children are Jewish he's great
with that he's greed he's not even he's
not he's got
moments like this and the reaction from
fan bases like this and how like
comfortable people like Jason Whitlock
for example get straight up saying like
the media is controlled by Jews make me
truly understand why so many people are
careful about
not even uh not even allowing a little
bit of of
touchy things to be said that could be
even perceived as borderline
anti-semitic or borderline bigoted you
know what I mean because like so many
people in defense of Kanye West came out
and were so comfortable just straight up
being like well why can't he say it it's
true right and it blew my [ __ ] mind
that so many people were just like
straight up just holding on to that
resentment uh without ever analyzing it
I don't talk about anti system on the
internet because
I feel like people just use it against
me and then they go all he does he's
just another Jew complaining about
anti-Semitism but
in truth I feel like in terms of the of
the bigoted behaviors and races the
opinions you can hold people are the
most comfortable being anti-semitic like
you can just be pretty much openly
anti-semitic almost and like it's not
that big of a deal I feel like
I mean the reason why it's a big deal is
not because Kanye West is being
anti-semitic it's that uh Kanye West is
is such a powerful media figure that he
has die-hard stands some of which are
also even more anti-semitic than Kanye
is they feel emboldened uh but then also
people will act out on these desires or
uh further spread anti-semitic
conspiracies and try to legitimize it uh
you're just creating a larger Army of
anti-semites oh somebody asked what this
shirt is it comes out next month
um you know what I do like is that in
this very official letter from Chase
they address him as yay
yeah did he I think he might have that's
his name did he Ian would know did he
formally change his name to that uh I
think so yeah I think that actually just
is his name now yeah okay fire dear yay
the other thing about the bank thing too
that I was reading and this was more
just speculation but you know he just
blew up his [ __ ] Gap deal recently
and also now he's like attacking Adidas
which is
Adidas is the reason he's a billionaire
it's not his music 100. um and so that
whole thing is collapsing as well and
the account that's being uh that he's
getting kicked off of it's it's not like
a personal banking account it's like
it's like a commercial bank account and
for his LLC right and so you know his
you know arguably the bank they probably
did a risk assessment and we're like
we're not going to work with this guy
anymore he's way too volatile you know
he's
he's uh bombing out of contracts left
and right and I don't know it it seems
pretty reasonable for everybody I see
bro to anyone to associate with them
right exactly so toxic I'm surprised
that Adidas they said it's under review
I'm surprised they didn't outright be
like this isn't working yeah I mean and
by the way his Gap collab must have been
such a train wreck not because of
controversy but because it was
creatively awful super expensive it was
just horrible it was in [ __ ] giant
trash literally in giant trash bags the
whole thing was a disaster I don't think
people were buying no I don't think so
either I remember I went to the I went
to a mall like a month or two ago
um on like a weekend and it was packed
it was like yeah [ __ ]
juicing in there yeah and the Gap was a
[ __ ] ghost town there was nobody in
there and just a stupid giant trash bags
that's not good just giant black trash
bags full of his clothes just sitting
all over the store nobody was interested
I always found that partnership so weird
like Gap and yeah easy it's just I don't
get it
I mean he took shots at Virgil ablo
um and some more information was
revealed about their their tumultuous
relationship it's obvious that he had
like a lot of resentment for Virgil yeah
I don't know Virgil was able to because
Virgil uh got the Louis Vuitton deal
which he thought was was his deal to be
had you know what I mean right he just
he just has so many Petty resentments
that have turned into these like
incredible lifelong blood feuds well now
he considers that he's saying Virgil is
my best friend and but you can tell them
yeah he said that uh being a BLM
Ambassador at Louis Vuitton uh just like
Barack Obama was a BLM Ambassador for
the white house uh is what aged them
rapidly and they actually killed Virgil
uh gave him cancer made him bald and
killed him that's what he said yeah it's
pretty incredible that he Compares
himself to Virgil because a lot of
people have opinions in the Fashion
World about him but what he built with
off-white is insane and so much more
than what Kanye ever has done in fashion
this is how by the way his clothing have
you seen this picture no this is how the
[ __ ] was laid out and got yeah I mean
look I I don't have an issue with his uh
designs I think like athleisure and like
skater culture made big waves within the
fashion community and I think Kanye West
played a role in that Kanye West is
right when he says he played a
significant role in like the Kardashian
brand getting elevated into like being a
a fashion brand you know what I mean
um but
uh and and I don't even disagree with
him when he says like uh a lot of these
Mega corporations exploit black culture
and black people in general uh but
ultimately the the solutions that he
offers to that problem uh are are
oftentimes either ineffective or
downright the exact opposite like
putting on a white lives matter t-shirt
is not going to be a solution to uh to
to white supremacist institutions right
it's it's ridiculous uh here is there oh
there's one worker constantly folding
the shirts and putting them back in the
trash bag
but that's over right is that [ __ ] all
gone no I went last oh it's still there
and still they're still full and they're
gonna be having crazy yeah I believe the
announcement was just that they were uh
not gonna renew it or they're winding it
down or whatever but it wasn't like I'll
go buy some of that [ __ ] wait till Black
Friday that's just all gonna be on heavy
duty yeah probably um
uh then after going on his anti-semitic
tour uh he shows up at the daily wire
Ben Shapiro's I mean this is just me
cornball Behavior I mean what the [ __ ]
these guys they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything with Ray J it's so weird my boy
Ray J Dude and Kid Rock Man prominent
voice sir I Hit It First uh-huh we love
you know we love me some Kid Rock yeah
made a song about his baby mama that's
crazy that is wild I mean that's just
well conservatives are cucks so that
that oh true true that is that is like
more conservative [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
ass up also kind of awesome that kid
rock is welcome at uh the daily wire
considering their current crusade to
defend uh children
um seeing as he is
in his music brags about uh hanging
miners on a regular basis wait Kid Rock
yeah
let me uh let me explain culture sweaty
dare you
we oh I want some bark hit rock bars
drop that [ __ ] on me uh while you look
those up here is uh Kanye West
being asked if he wishes harm on Jewish
people by TMZ if you're already being
asked that question you [ __ ] up yeah
you've gone too far
by the way TMZ does not claim us I love
TMZ they made an exception for us let's
give a shout out to them
what do you think's the film Kanye
I love
yeah oh no
dude he's oh [ __ ] crazy I know
that smile he got so scared watch this
[ __ ] he's like what [ __ ] what wait what
did he what did he say back to him is
that the only question you've got oh
okay yeah do you regret saying the your
comments about Jewish people this week
as well is that something you uh
trigger some controversy with your your
comments
do you think that the comment came to
the side of the blue I didn't think
there was a reason why I felt I presume
there's a reason so why you said what
you said
do you wish home on Jewish people no no
no no but I do feel that
in Hollywood
especially with black entertainers I've
had a lot of bad experience and if
people use that anti-semite idea to
cover up bad business to say hey if you
call somebody out on Bad Business that
means you're being anti-semitic so I
feel happy to have to cross the line of
that idea what the [ __ ] about even just
call out the individual that you had a
bad experience with even his [ __ ]
defense is still inherently anti-semitic
that's the problem let me read it
because it's kind of hard to say he says
no
but I feel that in Hollywood especially
with black entertainers I've had a lot
of bad experiences and people use that
anti-semi idea to cover up bad business
say hey if you call someone out on Bad
Business that means you're being
anti-Semitic
I feel happy to cross the line on that
idea so we can speak openly yeah he's so
brave he's such a bold truth teller he's
like we have to talk we have to be
anti-semitic sometimes you don't
understand this is tactical
anti-Semitism like no you can call out
the exploitative nature of Hollywood as
many artists have okay over and over
again without just somehow making it
about the Jews that's the problem the
anti-Semitism is the problem not the
fact that Hollywood is predatory and and
inherently exploitative and and abuses
and uses black bodies as though they are
disposable uh whether it be the music
industry whether it be a Hollywood
across the board right like this is that
that's real that's a real thing sure and
and of course
Kanye West's first day in experience
with that as a as a black Creator you
know but none of that none of the like
fighting against that uh is not going to
happen by wearing a white lives matter
shirt aligning yourself with Candace
Owens going to the premiere of like uh
you know an anti-black uh documentary
that the daily wires posting or saying
that you know Hollywood has bad business
and saying that is not anti-semitic no
saying that isn't anti-semitic but
that's not what you said right yo let me
read you this kid rock line are you
ready oh Jesus am I I don't know he goes
young ladies young ladies I like them
underage see
some say it's statutory but I say it's
mandatory
[Applause]
that is a real that's a Kid Rock song
yes what's the name of that song it's
called cool daddy cool
and it is from the Osmosis Jones
soundtrack Moses Jones for a children's
cartoon what the [ __ ] I don't think it
was like I don't think it was a kid's
movie I think that was more for by the
way that was one of the worst coaches it
was yeah it was like cartoon I know it
was a cartoon but I don't think it was a
kid's movie was it rated
uh let's see I asked what is a RAID you
said 50 I thought I thought you meant
the Rotten Tomatoes rating oh Osmosis
Jones uh it's rated PG PG oh [ __ ] me
that's yeah that's pretty young
yeah I remember going to see that movie
it had Chris Rock and Bill Murray I was
like how could this be bad I was the
only person in the theater man it was
the only time that ever happened to me
one [ __ ]
one group of people me and my friends
side note when Kid Rock talked [ __ ]
about Beyonce and her fans ruin his
social media posts what did he say about
Beyonce oh he doesn't know how she's so
popular and oh kid Rocky like you're to
talk seriously the bow with the bow
please [ __ ] her fans destroying getting
your [ __ ] get in line idiot what a
stupid [ __ ] how dare you say that
about anyone he couldn't post anything
without there being bees everywhere is
that still to this day it you'll still
see it a little bit
um I checked not too long ago actually
but it's not as common as it was yo I
still wrapping my head around that line
um young ladies young ladies I like them
underage see
some say that's statutory but I say it's
mandatory oh yeah yeah I mean that's
like that Jesus that that was the
fundamental plank of like rock music for
for many many decades yeah you know true
wait it wasn't that but Osmosis Jones
wasn't like during that age no no no I
know which is what I'm saying is he's
just like bringing it back he's keeping
that momentum alive yeah as most Jones
came out in 2001.
what are people's simping for Kid Rock
in the chat no no no for Kid Rock
uh I see people saying they love that
movie though yeah why I didn't say it
was bad I I like I thought it was better
than
um
then people gave a credit for I liked
the movie I don't know why I remember
liking it I like Osmosis Jones I don't
remember that bro I don't remember the
Kid Rock song yeah so uh so that's
basically the whole Arc there on Kanye
uh Elon uh just to touch on this because
it's in the title Elon Musk is trying to
Pro a broker uh peace in the Ukraine and
trying to broker a piece between Kanye
and the Jews he's all over the place
he's got a lot on his hands he's a deal
maker he uh has proposed just giving
Ukraine to Russia why don't we just
appease
uh Putin that'll that'll play well
Korean Russia please redo elections and
Annex regions under U.N supervision
Russia leaves if that is the will of the
people well that's going to be a little
difficult because like that that has
there's a displacement that has already
occurred at that point
um he says Crimea formerly part of
Russia as it has been since 1783 until
khrushchev's mistake that one I'm not
going to touch on
um I think that that was something that
zielinski not the formerly part of
Russia but that was something zielinski
was like willing to push back 15 years
into the future because there was an
original 15-point uh peace treaty and
negotiations that took place that they
kind of blew up uh water supply to
Crimea assured that's understandable and
Ukraine remains neutral like you know I
love this I love just the idea of asking
Twitter Twitter what do you think let me
know what you think y'all and Twitter
rejected anyway so I guess
he actually lost the pole yeah that's
pretty bad but he said it was Bots
attacking it or something he but it
doesn't
and then this conservative think tank
guy said
um he got off the phone with Elon Musk
and he told him he was on speaking with
Putin and the Kremlin directly about
Ukraine
he also told me what he said kremlin's
red lines were
the red lines
uh he did not say unfortunately but Elon
Musk did say nobody should trust Bremer
which by the way is not saying
that he's lying
just that nobody should trust him he's a
snake
um what do you what's your thoughts on
Elon Musk talking to Putin about the
situation in Ukraine is it neutral is it
weird is it I wish we lived in a world
where like it wasn't one [ __ ]
psychotic uh kleptocratic dictator uh
ruining the lives of millions of people
and then like a solution to that was
another like billionaire oligarch from
the West trying to have a conversation
with them you know these things would
not happen if we didn't have such uh
such a concentration of power at the top
for people that we basically uh see as
deities you know what I mean but that's
capitalism for you but is this good bad
neutral like what's your take on the
fact that they're talking I think
Vladimir Putin's gonna do whatever the
[ __ ] Vladimir Putin wants to do as he
has demonstrated I think again even if
it directly hurts the overarching goals
that he claims he has set for himself
whether it be the fake reasoning behind
like the denotification of Ukraine which
is [ __ ] [ __ ] like the only thing
you do when you invade a country is
embolden the most reactionary within
that country if your goal is to
undermine the influence of NATO the only
thing that you do when you kill uh you
know thousands of people is is galvanize
the position of NATO within Western
Europe Eastern Europe all parts of
Europe uh and and you know that all
tactically is also a misstep so on top
of it being obviously immoral gross a
human rights violation through and
through so uh according to Vice he
actually spoke to Putin before putting
out his uh pull
but
yeah I think you're right I think Putin
Putin is going to make a useful idiot
out of Elon I mean he already has pretty
I do think ultimately there needs to be
an off-ramp for uh for Russia if you
want to avoid further conflict and
further Bloodshed how can we do but it
doesn't yeah but it doesn't seem like
it's gonna happen how can like what's a
reasonable off-ramp that doesn't include
them stealing land from Ukraine the
reasonable off ramp would probably be
somewhere along the lines of the Minsk
agreement if you want to consider like
uh LPR DPR as like autonomous regions
that are still a part of Ukraine but I
don't think that's something that
Ukrainian people wanted it initially and
it's certainly not something that uh you
know Vladimir Putin even wants at this
point it seems like it seems like he
just wants uh the entirety of uh the
eastern Ukraine uh Ukrainian front to be
uh completely annexed and a part of
Russian territory which is is ridiculous
yeah I'm getting a little worried about
the situation out there because yeah and
they're talking absolutely [ __ ] by
Ukraine rain yeah and
there's what I you know unfortunately I
have to go because I have a call okay so
uh well hopefully the bombs don't drop
for next week
uh but we are safe underground the rest
of you are [ __ ] yeah good luck good
luck out there
I mean we're in La we would definitely
if there was like all out nuclear war
I've accepted that we're done LA's not
safe yeah no we're we're Gonzo Middle
America safe safer than the coast for
sure yeah LA's not the best let's go
let's go to Arkansas
I go well if I'm in the Valley am I safe
uh it's probably safer than the rest of
La well here we're not safe Woodland
Hills yeah no we're dead we're dead
we're dead dead here yeah maybe those is
all right Encino maybe not yeah but you
better pray that you're not at work when
that bomb drops yeah because you're
vaporized here boy
and we'll just make it fast right Hassan
yeah all right thank you guys
uh appreciate y'all
let's keep it uh
let's take my Geo card please I'm
begging you here so I'll take it
free charge God damn it all right see
you next week right thanks
[Music]
okay